Arena we've analyzed and re-analyzed
everything that was happening on the
board we've mentioned your sentiments
her sentiments what are your initial
feelings after this incredible matchup
yeah well
it's hard to you know I was in a in a
definitely feeling very bad after that
game in the classical time control where
I managed to lose I would say like
Unthinkable position like you can't
really lose that position you have so
many ways to play and I and I uh and I
achieved that so you know then you're
left feeling like you know
it's like how do you lose out of nothing
you know what I mean like it wasn't it
wasn't like even harder for me to play
and so to lose that and you're like okay
well why did this happen you know and
how am I going to come back and then
you're spending the next hour before
your
um a rapid tie break just trying to uh
get back into a
a normal frame of mind and it was also a
feeling of a trend shifting from your
side to her side because this was the
first game that she actually defeated
you either In classical or Rapid or
Blitz this was a big shift how did you
recover from that did you call your
coach did you go look over some lines
what did you do yeah I did not look at
any chest in between
um in that hour there wasn't really any
point it was clear that was not going to
be useful
um I did talk to my coach you know just
generally about you know how to approach
the match and actually the best thing
that we did is we started talking about
the future Fisher random chess something
to do nothing with my game and we talked
about my game obviously but we moved on
to talking about what's the future of
Chess you know what's happening to
classical chess why are the games you
know getting not as interesting as they
could be you know and um how quickly
Fisher random is going to arrive and all
the advantages of that for a sportsman
so you know believe it or not that was a
very tricky conversation because I think
we understood like that was the point
like talk about something else and
actually once I got done talking about
Fisher random I felt you know a lot
better that's very interesting just
change the topic all together and come
back to the game refreshed guys yeah
join the conversation our
congratulations Arena really really
fantastic stuff one of the things that
really helped us as commentators was the
large number of decisive games that uh
the American Cup produces your thoughts
about the large number of decisive games
yeah well I mean I think the format is
great because they're going to be
decisive games no matter what even if it
starts out kind of slow in the classical
chess
um you're gonna you know make the
players play some decisive games
eventually so I think the format you
know is wonderful
um it's exciting I mean matched uh match
play I think is probably the uh the most
exciting format in chess right you just
like direct matchups and you have
everything classical you know rapid
Blitz and
um you know I love this format then
hopefully I contributed a little bit to
the excitement in the tournament yeah
and Irina did you do any special
preparations for this event
you know nothing too special you know of
course I always want to prepare more
it's always the things like I start
thinking about it you know as soon as I
get my invitation but honestly in my
schedule it's just been so busy that I
mean I I almost never feel like I get to
do what I want you know in advance of
the tournament but I did do something of
course and
in fact you know I started thinking
about Alice you know before I even
played my first match you know back home
um I mean I knew I wasn't going to face
her early on but somehow it was just my
intuition telling me like I could and so
I um I actually did spend some time
thinking about our potential openings
and and some of that I was able to use
it in in our matches
Arena won a final question what is next
for you you have so many fans around the
world where they can see you next yeah
um well next is going to be very soon
actually guys first of all next you're
probably gonna see me on YouTube I'm
sure I'm gonna do some videos about this
tournament and
um you know some of these key moments
and after that I'm going to be going
very far away long trip to
um the country of Kazakhstan for the
world championship match between Ding
and nepo and I'll be commentating
alongside a very illustrious lineup so
it's going to be such an honor to
comment on the first four games with
vishyanand and then with danil dubov and
uh just a quick question about uh the
commentary thing and Napper who's your
favorite or who's your pick to win the
event
yeah that's hard to say who's my
favorite between these two players I
mean I think they're both very nice in
general I like all chess players so
unless I'm like you know unless I'm
especially friends with them I will just
kind of it's hard for me to root against
someone you know like I don't know ding
at all personally but I think he's a
very nice guy you know from what I've
seen very nice humble I mean I don't I
know Jan maybe like just marginally
better and he also seems like a nice guy
so I mean I'm rooting for the chess
actually that's the way to answer it
right I'm rooting for the chess to be
exciting
um not too long and exciting
wonderful well have fun and our kind
regards to Vichy as well I'm sure you'll
enjoy uh calling the action with vishu
once again Arena you are the champion of
the American Cup well done thank you
thank you and I just wanted to say thank
you to Rex thank you to the St Louis
chess club uh for organizing this
tournament again and um yeah it's
wonderful wonderful event I'm sure we'll
see you next year yes
thank you